one of the hang-ups of having an awesome
modern complex mobile application is all
the stuff you got to do just to get it
working so the user is happy it seems
counterintuitive then that when you do
all that stuff before the app boots up
it can actually cause unhappy users my
name is Colt McAnlis and one of the
common problems with slow launch
performance is doing too much stuff
inside of your applications
initialization code remember that
anytime your app launches the system
will display a start up window until
everything is up ready and your app has
been drawn the longer the users are
staring at this window the less happy
they generally get with your application
now a common scene all the time problem
that can cause this is spending too much
time and processing cycles in the
initialization of custom application
objects now while it's really important
to do some types of global work here
remember that the rest of the
application launching process can't move
forward until this initialization is
finished
and don't go wrong sometimes this isn't
intentional I mean it's not like you're
going out of your way to put lots of
work in this object application
subclasses tend to become repositories
for the full set of potential things an
app may need to be initialized for all
the possible activities in your app the
result is a lot of wasted work in the
most common cases now particularly
difficult in these situations is when
you get things like blocking code
garbage collection events disk i/o or
lots of network pings you know all the
heavy work that's sitting right in the
middle of the most critical step of your
initialization now before you run into
the weeds here trying to address these
issues it's worth figuring out if you
have a problem thankfully Android has
some tools to help first is the method
profiling tool which lets you
graphically see how long your
application on create method is taking
if it's going longer than 4 to 10
milliseconds then it's worth exploring
more to see what might be causing that
delay and to get that information you
can drill down by adding tracing
functions to your code which will then
show up in the next systrace capture
that you run for your application and
let's be clear the solution to all of
these problems is simple lazy loading C
while you can initialize subclasses and
systems for all activities your app will
need doing all this stuff up front is
just complete overkill so only a sub
set of these items are actually critical
for the main activity and thus those the
only ones that should be worked on the
rest should be deferred to some later
time
basically this boils down to moving
things out of the critical path of the
application initialization and either
doing that work on demand like a
subclass for a particular activity or
doing that work in the background
allowing the results to be returned
asynchronously see performance is all
about user perception and the critical
path of launching your app is where
users can perceive slow down the most so
to figure out how to fix up the other
parts of your application make sure you
watch the rest of our Android
performance patterns videos on YouTube
and don't forget to join the Google+
community to chat with other brilliant
performance folks so keep calm profile
your code and always remember perf
matters
you